what is my stance on dad's not beautiful  tweets a lot of people were upset by  that and they're like oh people can be  beautiful at any size not really i know  that when i was like i lost a bunch of  weight going low-carb and when i was  overweight i was uglier  that's just how it is and i think that's  because you're actually healthier if  you're at a healthy weight so what do i  think i think that  putting your views out on twitter is a  waste of time  but i don't see anything wrong with what  he said it's sports illustrated put on  somebody who's sporty and healthy  and athletic and being like well you can  be athletic if you're 400 pounds  probably you can probably be strong but  you're not healthy  objectively so i don't know i don't see  anything wrong with most of what my dad  does i think he's a little inflammatory  but it's kind of funny i think it's kind  of funny